i thought for once i'd talk about my own
science yeah which i don't usually do i
usually talk about more general things
in science but talk about some of the
research that i've been doing or
actually perhaps more correctly some of
the research that
mostly tom peterkin who's my phd student
has been doing time slicing time slicing
spiral galaxies with sdss4 manga what
does that mean
where do we start to tell the story we
probably need to back up a bit and talk
a little bit about galaxies here's a
couple of galaxies a couple of nice
spiral galaxies and we can come back to
talk a little bit about what the
hexagons mean but for the moment just
look at the pictures of the galaxies
probably the most telling difference
between these two pictures is that one
of them is blue and the other isn't
stars of different masses have different
colours the most massive stars tend to
be blue and then the less massive stars
tend to be red so whenever you see blue
light that tells you there are massive
stars there which means that the stars
must have formed recently a blue color
tells you that a galaxy is actively
forming stars and a red color tends to
tell you that it probably isn't so
actively forming stars what slightly
complicates the story is that there are
other things that can make galaxies blue
or red as well so for example if a
galaxy appears red it could be that it's
intrinsically blue but there's a whole
load of this dusty material between you
and the galaxy and dust tends to absorb
the blue light but let the red light
through so you just end up just seeing
the red light so it could be a dusty
galaxy the other possibility is it could
be a galaxy that has a lot of heavy
elements in it
in that heavy elements absorb light at
different parts of the spectrum and they
tend to be better at absorbing blue
light than they are at absorbing red
light so therefore you end up absorbing
a bunch of the blue light that would
have been emitted but you still see the
red light fortunately you can do a bit
better than just looking at the colors
and in particular you can split the
whole thing up into the complete
spectrum so all the colors of the
rainbow and study in detail what the
light is at different wavelengths here's
an example of what happens when you do
that and this is looking at different
stellar populations and there are
different things in here that there are
different ages of stellar populations
and there are different amounts of heavy
elements but the only things really to
take away from this is so this is
basically how much light there is as a
function of wavelength starting at the
blue end of the spectrum and ending up
at the red end of the spectrum so this
is the intensity of light it's kind of a
continuum and then there is these little
dips very specific wavelengths and these
dips are where some particular chemical
element is absorbing starlight so this
whole very kind of regular series of
lines here for example all due to
hydrogen and as i say these different
lines are for different assumed ages and
different assumed heavy element
abundances and they're all different so
you can actually sort of disentangle all
these different effects so if you were
to
to take the spectrum of a galaxy
you could actually use this kind of
information to tell why the galaxy was
red why it was blue and sort of
distinguish between these different
effects one of the games we can now play
are with things called integral field
units or ifus where instead of taking
one spectrum at a time you take a whole
bunch of spectra from all across the
face of a galaxy so we can do this kind
of across an entire galaxy all in one go
and so actually this hexagon on these
pictures are sort of the footprint of
the area where we've actually been
playing this game and the reason why
it's a hexagon is because the way that
this is actually done in practice for
this particular survey is that there's a
whole bunch of optical fibers which have
been arranged in a hexagonal pattern and
each of those fibers captures a little
bit of light and gets fed into a
spectrograph and the spectrograph across
the spectrum so essentially we can kind
of record the spectrum at every point
across the entire face of the galaxy and
so this is actually a survey it's this
thing called manga it's a project i've
been involved in for a number of years
now there's hundreds of astronomers
involved in it it's part of an even
bigger project called the sloan digital
sky survey the manga project is doing
this essentially there's a recording
spectra all across the face of the
galaxy for 10 000 galaxies so that's one
part of the thing that's new that we can
actually do this kind of analysis across
entire galaxies at a time the other bit
that's new and the bit that my phd
student tom's been working on
is that what he's been able to show is
that actually
you can do better than just saying is it
this or this in that this assumes that
the gap you know that all the stars of
the galaxy are one age right they're all
10 billion years old or they're all a
billion years old of course in a real
galaxy that's not what happens in a real
galaxy there's some stars which are
young stump stars reaching middle age
some stars which are old and of course
the light you get from them will just be
the sum of all those different spectra
what he's been able to show is you can
kind of disentangle it which means that
you can take a spectrum and say ah this
bit of the galaxy is 30 old star 60
middle-aged stars
and the remaining 10 is young stars or
something like that so you can actually
disentangle all these different things
and that's this thing called time
slicing that essentially we take the
whole galaxy and say okay so 10 percent
of the light is young this amount is
middle-aged and so on we can actually go
through the entire life history of the
galaxy
and kind of split it up into his parts
so this actually is for this gallery one
of those galaxies i showed you before
this actually is this galaxy it has a
very uninspiring name you know the
parlance of this survey it's eight three
two nine minus one two seven oh one oh
it needs a name what's your student's
name again tom peterkin peter king's
galaxy peter king's galaxy there you go
that's better so here we are going
through
and slicing through the galaxy from the
oldest stars to the younger star so we
start with the oldest stars here in the
middle and then we go through
middle age stars
youngest stars so the first thing is
just formal right in the middle very
centrally concentrated over time it grew
outwards formed this disc around it and
then the latest stars we're seeing now
are forming in the spiral arms that's
when new stars happen at spiral arm
exactly so it's actually telling you
this is where star formation is
happening now because actually that's
the strong most intense star formation
hams in the spiral arms the other
interesting piece of information
remember i said not only do you get the
ages of the stars but you get to learn
about what their heavy element
abundances are as well
and the slightly sort of
counter-intuitive thing is the color
coding here is basically telling you
what the heavy element abundances are in
the reddish colors of the highest heavy
element abundance and the bluest colors
are the lowest heavy element abundances
and so what you can actually see is that
those first stars to form is quite red
and so they have a lot of heavy elements
in them now that doesn't seem to make
much sense because remember i said the
way you get the heavy elements is by
having successive generations of stars
and yet you'd have thought the first
thing starts to form there can't have
been successive generations of stars to
make that happen what this is telling
you is that in that inner region there
must have been a very quick turnaround
of making lots and lots of stars and
many generations of stars very quickly
to kind of crank up that heavy element
abundance and then as the thing grew
outwards you're making more and more
stars out of more and more kind of
pristine material that's falling into
the galaxy that hasn't been through so
many generations of stars so that i
guess probably is not something you
would have sort of assumed if you hadn't
actually seen the picture here you might
have assumed that the stuff in the
middle should have the lowest heavy
element abundance whereas actually this
is telling you that the story is a bit
more complicated than that and actually
there must have been lots of generations
of stars in the middle and it's telling
you that the stars are being made from
new material coming from outside not
what's been spat out by the old dead
guys for the most part although it
doesn't have zero chemical and heavy
element abundances so it's it's sort of
telling you that there must have been
some processing within the disc but
actually it's more pristine it's it's
it's it's more kind of new gas falling
in that's making those outer parts of
the galaxy
the technical aspect of doing this is
quite difficult in that you've somehow
you this at this aspect of it of
disentangling all those different
components to figure out uniquely what
the thing was made of
is actually really quite technically
challenging and complicated so a lot of
the process has been going through a lot
of testing to say you know if we make a
make a galaxy ourselves where we know
what the components are and then we kind
of sort of pretend to observe it and add
a bit of noise as we would actually get
in a real galaxy
can we then get back out what we put in
in the first place and so there's a lot
of testing you need to go through in
order to do this to convince yourself
you really are doing this slicing things
up in time rather than just randomly
fitting components
if you have a jet of material coming out
of the centre of a galaxy and it starts
to wiggle around that's probably this
kelvin helmholtz instability as well
it's basically wherever you have two
streams of material traveling at
different speeds this instability will
kick in